who's Paul Finebaum the voice of the SEC
the SEC network commentator live from
SEC Media Days in Alabama today and
tomorrow on the SEC network Paul good
morning do we have any drama at sec
media days well yes we do Nick Saban
just walked into the hotel here and
about 500 of his faithful were screaming
and I'm sure Nick Saban will be
addressing the the Rory McIlroy comments
is he like Elvis uh I I was in I was I
grew up in members I think he's bigger
than Elvis he solicited dad I've covered
this man for many many years but someone
said you think Nick Saban dreads walking
in this hotel I think he he loves it i
mean walked in you know I I covered this
by the way but I haven't seen anything
quite like it since Moses parted the red
streak and fans are screaming they I
went out to meet someone about 5 45 this
morning they were already a hundred or
two fans and it's not like they said I
don't have a latte with lesabre I mean
they're just screaming his name he looks
up he gives kind of a very awkward
almost a feminine wave because he you
know you know [ __ ] he's not really an
extrovert I mean he doesn't like to talk
to people unless he has to so it's just
humorous and then 15 20 30 cameras
follow him around like he's about to be
named Donald Trump's vice presidential
running mate how good is his team this
year uh by normal savings standards
they're off a little bit which means
that they'll probably go 11 and one when
the SEC and be in the college football
playoff but for the third year in a row
man they don't have a quarterback last
year of course i had jacob coker a
transfer graduate transfer Florida State
this year they're the Graduate transfers
went to the big one went to a mmm that
was Trevor Knight of Oklahoma so but
that doesn't matter lane kiffin is still
there even though he probably doesn't
want to be
as long as kiffin is running the offense
and they have five stars across the line
on defense and a wide receiver they'll
they'll probably win again why doesn't
Lane Kiffin probably not want to be
there well I la different of three years
ago fired by SC he took this job on a
one-year deal thinking it would lead to
a head coaching position even after two
sec titles in the national championship
for whatever reason he is still toxic
with athletic directors and I think
that's frustrating to him because I
think he's really a pretty good coach
and he's shown what a great offensive
fine he is but athletic directors I mean
tell me this how could you hire Will
Muschamp it South Carolina who failed at
florida / / lane kiffin whoo-hoo we
didn't have great success at Southern
Cal but but but shows a great deal of
imagination well I also think
personality plays a role you can be you
can have no personality and being a
great coach and be like saving and
Belichick but you have to be a great
coach I think there's part of that now
where you got to win press conferences
and Lane wasn't he wasn't a great
personality when it came to that no he
he lost press conferences like 49 to
nothing um but yeah he is kind of an
interesting guy and I once criticized
him so I'm not gonna talk I've always
been on the lane kiffin bandwagon but
but but I think what he's done in
Alabama two years is Israel is is
remarkable man yeah I hope he gets
another chance I mean I heat he couldn't
even get an interview last year at
Syracuse I mean I got an interview
talking to Bob Finebaum the voice of the
SEC the old Miss situation hugh freeze
and the NCAA what kind of questions are
being asked is he being asked questions
about that at media day he'll be here
tomorrow and it will be a circus he
freezes just almost received this notice
validations and they're serious
allegations but since then he freeze has
gone on a speaking tour across the
country giving interviews and every time
he talks he makes the situation worse he
gave an interview this week the ESPN
where he said coach
were calling him offering support and
that was after reporting sports
illustrated by Pete Thamel that said a
number of coaches including one
prominent sec head coach questioned the
n-c-double-a saying if they don't do
something about this soon it's going to
be like the wild wild west so he he's in
the spotlight tomorrow yesterday the big
story was this five-star defensive
lineman Geoffrey Simmons he was shown on
video beating up a woman who had been an
altar in an altercation with his his
sister in his neighborhood when he was
in high school he was suspended for one
game by Mississippi State against South
Alabama there are 32 points favorite in
that game and Dan Mullen said they're
thrilled to have him on campus so that's
that's another buzz story making around
here in Alabama how much do you guys
miss Steve Spurrier badly sweet we had
Steve on our show Monday uh he wasn't
here but he was he was promoting a book
which will be out I'm sure you'll be
inundated by Spurrier fans it's a pretty
funny book is coming out in five weeks
but he owned this event for all but two
years of the last 25 that's when he was
working for Dan Snyder in Washington but
but but he's you know a star he is no
one has taken this place yet Paul thanks
for joining us we appreciate it be
careful in Rio thank you Paul be kept
careful in sec country as well Paul
Finebaum the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience